Let's go right to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 0.
Forty seven fifty.
We are going to start today with our caller
from the for a zero area code.
Who's calling today from 4 8 0.
Hi, David, is this me?
Yes, it is.
What's your name?
Hi, my name is Joseph.
Hey, Joe, what's up?
Hey, so I've been a big fan.
I first heard about you on Joe Rogan and just
had a quick question.
So there doesn't appear to be any official
or constitutional mandate that the incumbent
president is required to hold a debate with
the opposing party's nominee.
Right.
Trump seems to gravitate toward controversy
and undermining our institutions.
And we're seeing in real time how he's trying
to propagate conspiracy theories about the
Obama Obama-Biden administration.
Yep.
How likely is it that as a strategy to undercut
Biden, Trump forgoes debating Biden altogether?
Listen, he's hinted at he can do as many debates
as he wants or none at all.
And it shouldn't be up to the Commission on
Presidential Debates to decide that that's
sort of been his thing like that.
He says he and the opponent, whoever at the
time we didn't know who it was going to be,
should just be able to sort it out and do
whatever they want, but that the Commission
on Presidential Debates shouldn't get to intervene.
I think there's only about a 15 percent chance
that this is just me pulling a number that
Trump just refuses to debate altogether.
I don't see it as particularly likely, especially
because I think Trump sees himself as winning
the debates for sure.
And so I have a hard time imagining he'll
really go through with this, not doing the
debates.
But it's not completely outside the realm
of possibility.
OK.
If you don't mind and I just want to maybe
another question.
Do you think that with the lack of the campaign
rallies because of the pandemic right now,
that it's going to hurt Joe's chances of winning
over voters?
Not on balance.
I mean, listen, the polls only give us a snapshot
of what's going on right now.
Trump's been failing on Corona virus and Biden's
just been doing interviews from his house.
And Biden right now is doing fine in the polls.
I think that the risk to Joe Biden is if Trump
starts doing rallies again, particularly in
battleground states and Joe Biden, because
the public health officials say that this
is probably not a good idea.
Joe Biden abides by it.
That's where you could see it start to hurt
Joe Biden.
But right now, I don't think it's hurt him.
And I don't think we can really find data
that suggests that it has.
You so much.
All right, appreciate the call.
Thank you.